have you had a small dick before mmm-hmm
they're my favorite kind hey don't [ __ ]
your vagina no pressure and giving you
when I give head to smaller dick I feel
like a [ __ ] queen yeah cuz you can
get it all the way to the parlor types
myself but you know we'll talk about
that yeah I already know what vagina
go ahead every vagina change my
perception go ahead my purse survive
three two one smile if your heart is
breaking smile something something
something smile hey whitey were you
looking at why did why do what I'm when
I'm performing whitey right you pay
attention to every detail I love you and
thanks for thanks for changing for the
last 400 years you guys been acting wild
and over time especially now you guys
have changed a bit thank you so much for
that because now we get to make some
money - I'm gonna introduce people in
the [ __ ] room gab gab this is Gilbert
handicapped sister she uh she came here
in a little tiny yellow bus a little
helmet yeah yeah yeah so if she doesn't
speak English she's just a Tiki statue
I'm standing there I mean if you put
another two of you put me on top of if
there was an island and I saw that ol
Tiki statue
my whole family loved your whole family
I would leave okay yeah yeah anyway we
got kalila like girlfriend of seven
years Wow
yeah marry her already [ __ ] real real
sad medical and yeah until I say you're
[ __ ] we got this guy Gilbert we got
George Kimmel the third why why people
do that like you have to say there's
three of us Filipinos do it - I had a
friend named six and seven we go that
far back that's right I also have a
friend named jingle and twinkle so
Filipinos go wild all right [ __ ] jingle
in twinkle nun as her government needs
this guests are I I have a history with
hmm it's a positive one and it's a
history of it started off with a little
weird oh it started off real weird I
think that I took it wrong I should have
been more understanding about it but I
want it because you know you know I'm in
therapy and you know I went through a
lot of trial I had a hard childhood and
I was resilient enough to get out of
that and to carve out a career for
myself this next lady is so resilient
she had a tough upbringing um she is so
resilient she is one of the biggest
comedy movie stars in the biz right now
she's killing the game um she we did a
show together for Comedy Central where I
could I was sweating yellow goop blood
dad that's I was sweating yellow goop
blood when she was onstage
I remember just out of my little dick
she is just very talented so funny
Tiffany Haddish everybody yeah why did
we first meet the first time we met
officially yeah was in front of the
Laugh Factory yeah I was doing comedy
playground with Kevin Hart and Chris
Spencer in everybody and Pookie was
executive producing it and Pookie wanted
to do like a prank kind of show and so I
was dressed up kind of
butch like and you had a came to the
club you're gonna do a spot you're on
our show and you came up with your
girlfriend at the time it was like
probably 12 years yeah and and I was the
the prank was I was gonna say that you
were calling my girlfriend and about the
beach OS he was [ __ ] scared I didn't
really know her right now you know me
yeah yeah so I got scared and then I go
who the [ __ ] is that
yeah you were freaking freak you was
[ __ ] scared yeah I was like man you
are you calling my girl
[Laughter]
you know [ __ ] you one so then right you
know I have this thing of um it's a part
of my character defects I guess but I go
what's her name she just embarrassed me
right if somebody said Tiffany Haddish
and I poured that right yeah he's like a
[ __ ] hate and then every time I would
see you know more or less I dress like a
butch lesbian or anything I'm like hey
it's me hey Bobby it's me Tiffany like
that was funny I'm like I don't like you
get on my face leave me alone that was
[ __ ] up what you did yeah I apologize
it was just a prank it's not real sorry
but you know but but because but she is
right for years she was so nice to me
yeah well I was nicely I met you before
that but you didn't I don't think you
remember I was really young yeah Comedy
Store yeah like you're the funniest
Asian guy I know you know Thanks walk
away but you know there would came a
time maybe three or four years after
that mm-hmm and this is running into her
like you know 12 times a year she's just
so sweet and saying hi to me even
sometimes I wouldn't even say hi back
yep she kept do
wing it it's baby I'm sorry constantly
killing them with the kindness yeah and
then with the kindness and and finally
he's like who the [ __ ] are ya yeah
little conversation yeah we've been cool
and we've been cool ever since and and
this is way before you know her
explosion yeah yeah yeah but you know
you grew up like where did you grow up
in South Central Los Angeles where in
will your parents know so my